Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Sag mal, wie steht eigentlich der Bitcoin schon lange nicht mehr geguckt.
Ist noch Luft nach unten.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer vierhundertundfünfunddreißig vom dreizehnten Juli zwanzig zweiundzwanzig. Da sind wir wieder äh erholt von der Fusion.
Äh super Spezialist irgendwie einen riesen Aufwand getrieben habe, um eine Multitrack-Aufnahme zu machen.
Am Ende nicht aktiviert hast.
Die ich dann irgendwie, wo ich irgendwie das falsche Setting ausgewählt hatte und.
Habe ich dahin gefahren Tim, also insofern der Aufwand hielt sich ja auch in Grenzen für dich.
Na ja, ich äh konnte das dann nicht auf mir sitzen lassen und äh musste das dann sozusagen nachträglich in in Sprechanteile aufteilen. Gerechte Strafe für mich.
Das war bestimmt eine schöne Arbeit.
Das war ganz toll. Aber mittlerweile mache ich das so in so einem Zähnenmodus. Also das funktioniert äh schon ganz gut.
Und hast du heute? Nee, heute ist Multitrack.
Heute ist Multitriki ist eigentlich immer Multitrain.
Multitrack eben, ne?
Man muss ja mehrgleisig äh laufen, ja. Auch bei äh auch im Investmentbereich. Ja, man muss sich da.
Ja, nicht alles auf einen NFT.
Diversifizierung ist äh ganz wichtiges Thema so.
Ja, die Investition hat äh auch einen Kommentar zu bekommen.
Ja. Ja. Ja.
Willst du vorlesen, warum Zoo nicht spendet.
Falls ihr wissen möchtet, warum ich nicht spende, ich.
Habe ich die ganze Zeit gefragt. Ich habe da immer gesessen warum schwendet Zoo nicht?
Ja, das war mir auch immer ein Rätsel.
Jetzt kommt die Aufklärung.
Ich mag es nicht, dass ihr mich mit eurem Gender-Deutsch unsichtbar macht. Eure männliche Zielgruppe und Haupthörerschaft ist euch nicht wichtig Fragezeichen? Dann braucht ihr auch mein Geld nicht.
Wollen deine Euroninnen auch gar nicht.
Wir wir kriegen die nämlich von Os der sagt macht nichts, ich spende genau deshalb leitet sie also aus, wenn du vom Podcast her grundsätzlich unterstützen willst, kannst du es jetzt also machen. Bussi.
Äh
Wir haben da lange kein Feedback mehr zu bekommen, dass äh ich äh primär äh einfach im generischen Femininum spreche. Gibt aber auch manchmal Leute,
Also warte, mach's, mach's ja falsch. Haben wir jetzt hier gesehen. Äh aber äh der der eigentliche Kommentar, der glaube ich ganz interessant ist, war von Käthe, den fand ich ganz nett
Ich bin Hörerin, vielleicht hilft dir ein kleiner Schwank aus meinem Leben zu etwas Verständnis dafür, welchen Unterschied Gendern machen kann, wann immer ich in Stellenanzeige
lese, dass Elektrotechnikerinnen MWD gesucht werden,
denke ich daran, dass ich als Abiturientin nicht den Mut hatte, Elektrotechniker zu werden. Ich konnte mir nicht vorstellen
die Ausschreibung an mich gerichtet war, obwohl ich meinem damaligen Freund,
seinen Techniker machte in Mathe helfen konnte. Heute hingegen.
Hätte ich mich angesprochen fühlen können und meinen Traumberuf ergreifen können. Es geht beim Gendern nicht,
Die männliche Hörerschaft. Mir das für dich persönlich tut, wenn du dich tatsächlich daran störst. Auch ist es keine demokratische Sache, bei der die männliche Mehrheit der bestimmende Faktor ist.
Bitte mal einen Moment, welchen Unterschied es für dich schon macht,
Dein Geschlecht nicht exklusiv angesprochen wird, kannst du dir vorstellen, wie Kacke es ist, gar nicht angesprochen zu werden. Viele Grüße von einer Pädagogin, die noch immer davon träumt, auf Strommasten zu klettern.
Und gab dann auch direkt hier Cornrate, sagt der liebe Käthe, Daumen hoch für deinen Schrank. Tatsächlich hatte ich das Thema noch nie aus dieser Perspektive betrachtet. Sie leuchtet ein und ich bin schlauer durch deinen Beitrag geworden. Danke. Einen solchen Kommentar hat,
Zoo nicht bekommen.
Nee. Hat mich jetzt auch nicht schlauer gemacht.
Aber auch nicht dümmer. Na ja egal ich denke wir machen uns jetzt hier ein bisschen über Zoo lustig. Äh es ist diese gesamte diese Gender-Thematik ist ja politisch nach wie vor enorm aufgeladen,
Es gibt ja jetzt auch grade wieder sehr viele Menschen, die meinen, dass ihr gerechter Beitrag zur zum gesellschaftlichen Diskurs ist,
irgendwie transsexuelle zu bashen ja das äh wo ich haben noch nie einen Menschen,
gesehen, wurden so und meinen das da findet jetzt der gerechte Kampf statt, dass sie denen irgendwie ihre Lebensverwirklichung ähm,
erschweren wobei,
das ist so das ist so das das finde ich ganz ganz ganz niedrig.
Teile und Herrscher. Ja, es geht einfach bei diesen ganzen Diskursen nur dadrum,
andere Gruppen ausfindig zu machen, die denen die Mehrheit nicht angehört so und sie äh als bedrohlich für den eigenen Lebenswandel darzustellen
obwohl äh in der Regel dein Leben davon nicht tangiert wird so, mein Schwule tangieren mein Leben kaum, aber sind vor allem,
Selbst wenn sie's tun, ist es nicht schlimm. Ja, aber lange, lange Zeit war.
Schule, Schule tangieren mein Leben sehr viel. Ich habe sehr viele schwule Freunde und die empfinde ich als große Bereicherung.
Ja, vielleicht ist Tangieren jetzt nicht das richtige Wort gewesen.
Ja, das äh beeinträchtigen, die beeinträchtigen dich in deiner Lebensführung nicht. Genau. Und wenn sie's tun, dann nicht, weil sie schwul sind, sondern einfach ganz normaler Arschlöcher.
Ja oder blöd oder was auch immer, das kommt ja die besten äh Familien und auch in allen sexuellen Orientierungen vor. Nur.
Ja, auch lesbische, schwule Behinderte können ätzend sein.
Genau, aber äh darum geht es ja in diesen politischen Diskursen nicht, sondern es geht immer nur dadrum, irgendeine
gruppe ausfindig zu machen, der halt viele nicht angehören, ja, die sich auch in diese Lebenswelt nicht eindecken können und dann wird das halt irgendwie aufgeblasen und zu irgendeinem Feind oder Problem erklärt, um einfach davon.
Ablenken zu können, dass man nicht bereit ist irgendwie allen Leuten gleich Gutes zu wünschen und
zukommen zu lassen und ja heute sind es irgendwie Transsexuelle. Früher waren's halt,
Schule äh,
und viele, viele, viele andere Gruppen auch, ja, auch religiöse Minderheiten, es ist völlig egal. Bei all diesen Diskussionen geht's immer nur dadrum
irgendwelche Teilgruppen in irgendeiner Form zu einem Problem zu stilisieren, um da seine eigene radikale äh Agenda
verfolgen beziehungsweise diese ganze radikale Agenda wird nur aus einem Grund überhaupt verfolgt einfach um diese ganze Aufregung und diese aufgeblasenheit in der Bevölkerung, die sich dann,
alarmiert sieht und das irgendwie auf einmal als Problem dargestellt bekommt um um
dann da was gegen tun zu müssen und dann soll man halt diesen Vollhorst, der das irgendwie gerade gemacht hat, äh äh unterstützen, damit irgendwie Schlimmeres verhindert werden kann, von einer
Vor einer Bedrohung retten, die so gar nicht existiert so und ich meine, das ist halt einfach die faschistische Methode,
So und nichts anderes und deswegen äh muss man da einfach mal ein bisschen ruhig Blut bewahren. Also wir haben wirklich eine Menge Probleme, aber das gehört definitiv nicht dazu.
Wirklich nicht, wirklich nicht. Äh nicht so ja lassen wir das. Ähm,
ich habe das ja auch schon getwittert, ne, was äh viele von mir ja gar nicht wissen äh ich habe ich habe eigentlich ganz gerne recht.
Was?
Ja
Moment, ich muss die Webseite umschreiben.
Gar nicht so an. Aber äh ich finde schon.
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Ist schon so, ja, ja, okay, mhm.
Wer hat gesagt Mas, kauft Twitter nicht? Ich habe diesen Tweet noch mal rausgegoogelt. Da gab's einfach so wunderschöne Antworten, ja? Also ich hatte ja im,
Ähm wenn man das im am 15. April habe ich getwittert, kurz Manipulation via Twitter ist schon lang, Elon Musks Hobby. Das Ganze mit Twitter selbst zu machen, ist einfach nur ein lustiger Gruß aus der Küche, er wird nicht kaufen und dann kam halt so diese,
Masketiere, ja und haben dann irgendwie.
Und haben dann äh habe ich dann sicher keine Ahnung habe, wie wie geil keine Ahnung von Wirtschaft und so. Na ja, da habe ich dann spät dann drauf geantwortet.
Genau, was ist passiert? Elon Musk ähm hat,
Zweifel daran erhoben, dass die von Twitter kommunizierte Zahl von circa fünf Prozent seien Bots oder Fake-Accounts.
Äh nicht korrekt äh äh korrekt sein könnte ähm und hat dann äh Zugang zu Daten verlangt, die das belegen könnten, weil ähm natürlich ist,
wenn die sagen, sie haben fünf Prozent oder ist das ist natürlich entscheidend für den Wert des Unternehmens.
Weil sich ja der auch der Wert von Twitter letztendlich daraus bestimmt, was äh wie viele Nutzerinnen es hat.
Ja also er sagt ihm wurden nicht ausreichende Daten äh bereitgestellt, um das um die Angaben zu prüfen,
und entsprechend äh betrachtet er dies als Vertragsbruch,
und löst die Kaufvereinbarung auf. Ähm.
Glaube ich nicht mit durchkommen.
Also ich bin mal interessiert. Es gab so ein paar Tweets von Datenanalystinnen, die ich jetzt, wo ich mir nicht sicher war, wie man den ob also wie gut jetzt deren Analysen wirklich waren, aber die halt schon sagten so, na ja, also wenn man jetzt mal einfach,
Wenn Twitters Zahlen stimmen würden, was jetzt die Anzahl der Tweets und die Anzahl der aktiven Accounts angeht.
Dann haben sie halt mal geschaut und meinten, ja da müsste halt eigentlich jeder äh also da da gibt's ein Missverhältnis, weil es müsste jeder Mensch, jeden jeder Twitter-Account im Schnitt fünf Mal pro Tag twittern.
Das halte ich dann auch nicht für realistisch. Und dann haben sie jetzt so ein bisschen geschaut, wie viele Accounts haben überhaupt im letzten Monat getwittert?
Wahrscheinlich ein ziemlich guter Wert wäre für tatsächlich aktive Nutzung.
Also sieben Prozent oder sowas.
Also genau. Das äh,
Also dass da dass da Musik ist für relativ viel Interpretation und Streit ist klar und dass da der der Kernwert des Unternehmens liegt ist auch klar. Andererseits hat Twitter hat äh Musk aber auch gesagt,
Mein zentrales Agenda-Versprechen ist, dort die Bots loszuwerden,
Also in seiner hätte er gesagt, ihr habt zu viele Bots, die müssen wir loswerden. Das werde ich lösen, ja?
In dem ich wahrscheinlich einfach Geld dafür nehme oder was auch immer sein Plan ist, ja. Und wenn er dann sagt, nö, also viel zu viele Bots,
ähm wird der eventuell sage ich jetzt mal vor einem kritischen Gericht äh Schwierigkeiten haben.
Ähm und Twitter hat gesagt, na ja nee, wir verklagen dich jetzt, du musst kaufen.
Und alle denken ja was was willst du mitm Chef, der gezwungen wurde, das Unternehmen zu kaufen? Darum geht's natürlich nicht. Es geht jetzt darum, mindestens diese Milliarde,
Strafgebühr zu bekommen, um die werden sie zanken und oder.
Um einen geringeren Preis, denn äh Twitter ist äh inzwischen nur noch 28 Milliarden wert und Musk hat hier glaube ich 44 Geboten.
Das heißt, der wäre ja jetzt inzwischen schon sehr sehr stark überwehrt,
was auch einer der Gründe sein kann, dass er jetzt versucht äh zu sparen,
Ähm dann hatte noch ein äh Analyst äh argumentiert,
Mask habe den vermeintlichen Deal als Vorwand genutzt um Testeraktien im Wert von achteinhalb Milliarden zu verkaufen,
noch eine Milliarde Strafgebühr abzieht hat der trotzdem sich liquide Mittel in Höhe von 7,5 Milliarden,
verschafft dir jetzt sagen kann, oh, die sind jetzt auf einmal da. Ich verstehe nur nicht, was das Problem.
Braucht man da einen Vorwand.
Wahrscheinlich müsste er, wenn er so viele Tesla-Aktien verkauft, dass halt irgendwie klarer machen oder so. Also macht für mich alles.
Es nur deklarieren, aber da kenne ich mich jetzt mit den Details des äh Börsengeschehens nicht aus, aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht, warum das jetzt irgendwie ein,
er muss es halt nur ankündigen.
Leuchtet mir auch nicht ganz ein. Also die sehen sich jetzt vor Gericht, Twitter wird natürlich versuchen ähm,
an deren Stelle würde ich jetzt versuchen die Milliarde zu bekommen und ihn eventuell noch wegen Rufschädigungen und äh Kursmanipulationen noch irgendwie für Schadensersatz zu verklagen.
Auf Alkohol sperren.
Hätten sie machen sollen. Gab's ja ein sehr schön, es gab so ein Elon Musk Fake Account mit einem großen I.
Also und äh der ist suspendiert und da gab's halt einen sehr schönen Feed, der dann sagte so Elon Muske kaufen nicht Twitter, Twitter Doppelpunkt,
Hat dann einfach nur auf diese Couch gelingt, der jetzt das Fenned ist und alle so, boah, krass! Das wäre aber eigentlich geil gewesen, jetzt schüttet er den einfach mal geblockt hätte. Dann hätte er nämlich auf einmal doch wieder gekauft.
Na ja, die die zanken sich jetzt ähm aber es ist schon selten, dass derartige Kaufvereinbarung dann am Ende doch nicht zustande kommen und,
Am Ende sind beide jetzt grade in einer Scheißsituation, weil also Twitter,
geiles Unternehmen, das jetzt irgendwie jemanden verklagen will, dass er's kaufen muss. Gleichzeitig haben die jetzt eine relativ stabile also eine gute Aussicht auf gewinnen, weil irgendeine Strafe wird der zahlen müssen. Äh Mask,
wird jetzt zukünftig größere Schwierigkeiten haben, wenn er irgendwelche Kursmanipulationen durch angekündigte Deals herbeiführen möchte, das auch dauerhaft schlecht für ihn. Ähm,
Ich ich sehe zwei Optionen, also eine ist, sie einigen sich fürn auf einen sehr viel niedrigeren Kaufpreis.
Aber ich glaube es wird genauso sein, wie ich's gesagt habe.
Was mich so beunruhigt ist, der einzige Grund, warum er das irgendwie kaufen,
Wollen würde. Also man fragt sich ja immer, warum? Wozu was was weswegen was was willst du damit besser machen? Also denkst du wirklich, dass es jetzt irgendwie eine Investition, die am Ende Geld bringt?
Ist das irgendwie dein Grund? Da frage ich mich halt so, ähm,
keine Ahnung welche großartige Idee du da jetzt äh hast, die andere noch nicht
gehabt haben, ja, die das äh also so als Bezahlmodell irgendwie könnte man vielleicht halt auch mal drüber nachdenken, würde aber wahrscheinlich auch Schwierigkeiten haben.
Ich glaube, das haben wir in der Sendung, als er dieses Kaufangebot machte, äh haben wir das ja auch schon ein bisschen darüber spekuliert. Es ist der also es ist das.
Aber das andere wäre halt nur so ein neoliberale äh äh profaschistische Agenda um irgendwie sich die USA zu unterjochen, indem man den Disco äh Kurs äh komplett Einkauf.
Er seinen Kumpel Peter Fiel das jetzt noch.
Kommen wir mal zu äh interessanteren Themen. Das Innenministerium hat die Cyber-Sicherheitsagenda,
herausgegeben. Ich glaube so ein weiß nicht wenigseitiges Dokument mit acht Punkten,
Jetzt sagen, das ist wie in der 20. Legislaturperiode.
Nun äh Ziele und Maßnahmen definiert sind, um,
im Cyber jetzt äh Besserung, Linderung äh herbeizuführen. Das ist natürlich sehr interessant, weil wir haben eine neue Innenministerin. Wir hatten vorher,
ja Horst Seehofer das ist äh.
Er war der Name Programm und äh jetzt haben wir äh Nancy Phaser, die, so scheint mir,
Den Fehler gemacht hat, den Laden nicht einer Grundreinigung zu unterziehen, bevor sie da eingezogen ist,
Auch das geht natürlich nicht so einfach. Da sind ja auch relativ viele äh Karriere äh Politik, also Karrierebeamte. Ähm,
mit entsprechender Prägung, aber ich merke, wenn ich da ne mal in die Organigramme schaue, dann sind da einige Namen noch, die ich da schon sehr lange sehe und wo ich jetzt versucht hätte mal,
zu gucken, ob man die nicht dem dem Markt wieder zur Verfügung stellen könnte oder so, ja? So aber okay, schauen wir uns an,
acht Punkte, ich fasse sie mal ganz kurz, also ich lese sie einfach nochmal kurz vor. Cybersicherheits
Modernisierung und harmonisieren, Cyberfähigkeiten und digitale Souveränität der Sicherheits
Behörden stärken. Cyber Crime und strafbare Inhalte im Internet bekämpfen, Cybersicherheit der Behörden und des Bundes stärken. Cyberresilienz kritischer Infrastrukturen stärken.
Schutz, ziviler Infrastrukturen vor Cyber-Angriffen. Das wäre ja mal interessant,
Digitale Souveränität in der Cybersicherheit stärken, krisenfeste Kommunikationsfähigkeit schaffen und Sicherheit der Netze
ausbauen. Das ist der der letzte Punkt. Da haben sie das cyber vergessen mit reinzumachen.
Nicht genug Cyber drin.
Warnon, also sieben Cyberpunkte und einer hat was mit IT-Sicherheit zu tun.
Das ist tatsächlich dramatisch, wie sich dieser Begriff leider durchgesetzt hat, ne? Also ich ähm na ja, okay.
Fangen wir an. Erster Punkt, Cybersicherheitsarchitektur, modernisieren und harmonisieren. Worum geht's hier? Ähm
Wir haben Moment, IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei, da war ja meine äh Stellungnahme. Ähm da hatte ich dieses Schaubild drin, in der die IT
Sicherheitsagentarchitektur ähm mal dargestellt wurde von Sven Herpick ähm,
und da hatte ich äh das da ist auch einigen, die die Stellungnahme auch tatsächlich gelesen haben. Äh aufgefallen hatte ich dann so generell Empfehlungen. Die Bundesregierung möge mir einmal dieses Schaubild erklären oder jemanden finden, der das kann.
Und ähm.
Also Hintergrund ist etwas unübersichtlich.
Ist etwas unübersichtlich und hat das Problem, dass natürlich sechzehn Bundesländer hast und eine Bundesbehörde und da ist tatsächlich einfach eine äh absolute ähm Zuständigkeitsdiffusion gibt.
Was wollen Sie also machen?
Ausbau des Bundesamtes für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik zu einer Zentralstelle im Bund Länderverhältnis. Und äh Glau auch dann die unabhängige Rehaufstellung des Bundesamtes versichert in den Informationstechnik. Diese,
Wir haben immer gesagt, wir hätten gerne unabhängiges BSI, aber es soll immerhin ein unabhängigeres geben,
Ja, es ist ein G zu viel. Ein GE zu viel. Ähm und,
Dann wollen sie Zuständigkeitsverteilung im Bereich der Gefahrenabwehr im halber Raum anpassen. Es geht also insgesamt um
schon eine Konsolidierung hin zum Bund. Das geht nicht so ohne weiteres, weil äh dafür ich glaube sogar eine,
Grundgesetzänderungen notwendig ist, wie ich es höre. Kann's nicht einfach diese diese Kompetenzen den Ländern wegnehmen,
Ich denke aber, dass eigentlich allen einleuchten sollte, dass man dass es auch einfach nicht genug Kompetenz und Personal gibt, um sich 17 mal vorzuhalten und das ist wahrscheinlich sinnvoll ist, hier eine äh eine Bündelung zu machen.
Äh also das halte ich jetzt erstmal nicht für unsinnig, vor allem weil betrifft eben
BSI und so Scherze wie den nationalen Cybersicherheitsrat das nationale Cyber-Abwehrzentrum, eine Sicherheitsstrategie für Deutschland 2021 soll weiterentwickelt werden und
ja
Zuständigkeitsverteilung im Bereich der Gefahrenabwehr im Cyberraum riecht halt so ein bisschen nach Polizei. Da müssen wir mal gucken. Jetzt muss man sowieso über dieses Ding schreiben. Das, was ich gerade vorlese, das ist alles.
Ja, das sind immer hier so Bulletpoints. Mehr ist da nicht. Also das ist sehr ähm,
In einem sehr frühen ähm Stadium der Genese. Ähm ja also sieht erstmal nicht nicht schlecht aus. Man kann durchaus sagen, dass das BSI an vielen Stellen ähm,
vielleicht noch besser wirken könnte und äh ja unabhängiger finden wir auch erstmal gut,
Schwierig wird's beim zweiten Punkt, Cyberfähigkeiten und digitale Souveränität der Sicherheitsbehörden,
denn fragt man sich natürlich, welche Sicherheitsbehörde ist gemeint? Das BSI hatten wir doch unter Punkt eins. Ja,
Das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz ist ja unsere Sicherheitsbehörde, auf die wir so viel vertrauen und die so viel mehr Cyber für uns.
Verhindern könnte,
Ja. Ähm.
Hier steht dann jetzt so durch den Ausbau und die Stärkung technischer Ermittlungs- und Analysefertigkeiten und Instrumente bei den Sicherheitsbehörden
sorgen wir dafür, dass diese dem technologischen Wandel im digitalen Raum Schritt halten können und
Schritt halten und ihre gesetzlichen Aufgaben bei der Gefahrenabwehr und Strafverfolgung weiteren Bedarfsgericht wahrnehmen. Weiterhin für Daske. Also es ist schon sehr, sehr efemistisch.
Durch den Ausbau der zentralen Stelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich, das ist die ZITIS, ja.
Werden die Sicherheitsbehörden mit technischen Lösungen gezielt in ihren Ermittlungs- und Analysefähigkeiten gestützt.
So, also die ZITIS soll Ermittlungs- und Analysefähigkeiten unterstützen. Ähm Polizei und Nachrichtendienste profitieren gleichermaßen vom Ausbau,
Eigener nationaler Entwicklungsfähigkeiten und von der zentralen Bündelung der Investition und Entwicklungsfähigkeiten beizieht es. Ähm.
Also hier geht es natürlich um Offel, also um letztendlich,
Staatstrojaneranalysetechnik, Überwachungstechnologien, die bei gebündelt werden. Die meine schönste Maßnahme und Ziele für die 20. Legislaturperiode ist, die Schaffung einer gesetzlichen Grundlage für die CITIS.
Stimmt nämlich, ich muss ich habe das auch vergessen, die Zitis wurde einfach gegründet. Das hat Seehofer damals, glaube ich, einfach gemacht, weil ich das,
wir machen jetzt und normalerweise, wenn du eine Behörde haben willst, musst du ein Gesetz dafür haben,
Der hat das aber einfach gemacht. Das war auch damals, also Andre hat sich damit sehr sehr äh sehr detailliert auch auseinandergesetzt. Üblicherweise kannst du nicht einfach sagen, neue Behörde,
Pass auf, da bauen wir die hin. Und die Macht folgendes. Für den und den. Geil, ne?
Was als Nächstes. So, dann musst du halt schon irgendwie ein Gesetz für haben, ja? Das möchten Sie jetzt haben.
Geil. Wenn du Innenminister wärst, was würdest du denn da so als erstes für ein Institut gründen ohne ohne Gesetzesgrundlage? Konntest du was ausdenken?
Irgendwas mit Antifa? So eine Antifa Antifazentralamt oder so was. Zentralstelle für antifaschistische Aktion weil da würden die einfach so durchdrehen.
Und dann.
Und dann ohne gesetzliche Grundlage, weil sind Anarchisten, Alter, ist ja wohl klar, dass die ohne gesetzliche Grundlage arbeiten. Irgendwie sowas.
Steht doch also steht auch in der Verfassung, dass wir gegen Faschismus sind oder nicht. War das nicht so?
Für Antifaschismus und Heimat.
Das kommt immer gut an. Das ein Knaller, das machen wir.
Zentralstelle für zu Pflege antifaschistischen Brauchtums und.
Und das ist gut.
Ey Isi. Gut, aber mit so gesetzliche Grundlage wird dann nochmal längere Zeit diskutiert werden, aber nein, gut. Also zieht es so. Also meine Stimme hast du. Wählt Neumann.
Also meine Stimme hast du. Wählt Neumann. Jetzt brauchen wir noch eine passende Partei für dich. Müssen wir uns auch noch was einfallen lassen, ist schwierig.
Als unabhängiger Kandidat direkt Direktwahlinnenministerium.
Linus monarchistische Offensive. Okay pass auf. Lass uns weiter beim Thema bleiben.
Okay, pass auf. Lass uns weiter jetzt was Neues.
Basis basisdemokratische Monarchie. Machen wir. Ähm.
Basis. Ähm du weißt, du weißt, was die Basis auf auf Arabisch heißt, ne?
Äh Al-Qaida, nee, äh ja. Ja gut, äh wenigstens Leute mit klaren Prinzipien.
Was war das nächste Thema?
Also äh nee, nee, äh Cyber, so was möchten Sie für die Sicherheitsbehörden haben?
Eine umfassenden Digitalisierungsstrategie für das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz. Also das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz soll digitalisiert werden,
Ich find's auch immer schön, also es ist schon spannend, weil,
in all diesen Dingern verbirgt sich auch immer ein Defizit. Modernisierung der IT-Infrastruktur im Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz. Fortentwicklung der Cyber-Fähigkeiten des BFV,
deren nutzbaren Machung im Verfassungsschutzverbund, insbesondere Modernisierung von Recherchetools zur Aufklärung von Extremismus in sozialen Medien.
Sowie Datenhaltungsanalysesysteme beziehungsweise Tools bei der Aufklärung und Früherkennung staatlich gesteuerter Cyber-Angriffe. So da habe ich jetzt
Ähm also Extremismus in sozialen Medien ist ja ein Thema, dass äh Nancy Phaser wichtig findet, äh denke ist auch durchaus eins, wo jetzt ihre Aufmerksamkeit äh sagen wir mal Versäumnisse der letzten Jahre durchaus kompensieren sollte.
Äh Datenhaltungs- und Analysesysteme zur Früherkennung staatlich gesteuerter Cyberangriffe. Also.
Ich hatte da auch kurz mit dem äh mit dem Michael gesprochen. Der hatte mich dafür die Tages äh Show zu interviewt. Die stellen wie stellen die sich dieses Cyber vor? Früher kennen wir Früherkennung,
Ja klar, stell dir mal vor, plötzlich ist da ein Cyberangriff. Da müssen wir Früherkennung machen, da brauchen wir Raketen ab,
ab äh der Schirm. Wir hatten ja erst vor Kurzem die Sendung Hackbackrakete.
Das ist also es es gibt da so eine Streef davon von so falschen Vorstellungen, wie das funktioniert, ja. Später kommen wir noch zu okay, Früherkennung,
Leute, das ist TCP IP auf Glasfaser. Da müsst ihr richtig früh erkennen, so,
Da müsst ihr aber richtig blitzschnell müsst ihr da sein. Verbesserte Befugnisse zur Aufklärung technischer Sachverhalte bei Cyberangriffen fremder Mächte?
Wird's auch spannend, ja? Also hier geht's ihnen natürlich klar, beide Male hier staatlich gesteuert, fremde Mächte. Es geht ihnen um um Cyberwar.
Interessanterweise auch das ein Thema, was wir hier ausführlich immer wieder besprochen haben,
halt der, der Cyber-Awall, den Staaten führen,
Im Spionagebereich die ganze Zeit stattfindet und im Sabotagebereich eben eher auf die Wirtschaft und
dass wir in Deutschland, weißt du, jetzt alle sitzen da sagen, boah
Cyber War. Wann kommt der Cyberwall? Ist der Cyberwall schon? Wann war der Nummer? Ja und in Wirklichkeit werden seit sieben Jahren rasieren die mit Rancing Wagings durch die komplette Wirtschaft. Alle immer so
Bäcker braucht für dich. Ah Scheiße, Backup, äh jetzt hätten wir doch gern eins. Ja? Und niemand unternimmt etwas, ja? Es wird einfach so wahrgenommen und aber gleichzeitig seine, hoffentlich kommt kein Cyberwall.
Das wollen wir aber nicht.
So, Stärkung und Ausbau der Zentralstellenfunktion des BFV im Verfassung Verfassungsschutzverbund, also auch hier, Zentralisierung zum Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz würde ich zugunsten der Zentralstelle für antifaschistische Brauchtum auflösen,
aber,
wird ja nicht gefragt. Ausbau und der Ermittlungsfähigkeit und Instrumente des Bundeskriminalamtes und der Bundespolizei im digitalen Raum, in den Bereichen Automotive IT, Internet der Dinge und Verschlüsselung sowie bei der polizeilichen Nutzung künstlicher Intelligenz. Das auch
weißt du? Guck mal, uns gerade gesagt, unser also wenn es ein Problem grade zu lösen gilt in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, für die Wirtschaft, dann sind es,
Angriff. Wenn sie ein, also immer wenn du irgendwie cyber sagst, musst du sagen, wenn du irgendein Problem lösen willst, dann vielleicht das. Jetzt sagen die, das BKA muss dringend in den Bereichen Automotive IT, Internet der Dinge.
Also ich meine, da brennt's ja richtig. Wir sehen ja, wie die ganze Zeit die Autos gehackt werden, ja? Und unverschlüsselung, ja gut, da weiß dann auch, wie der der,
Also entweder die können Verschlüsse oder nicht, es geht natürlich um das Brechen vom Verschlüssen. Und künstliche Intelligenz. Also gut, dahinter dahinter verbirgt sich am Ende einfach irgendein Topf.
Ein Haufen Geld, dass sie dann irgendwie.
Das sind die Trägerworte, die halt in den Anträgen drinstehen müssen.
Äh Etablierung als wirksames Schwachstellenmanagements inklusive Installation der behördlichen Prozesse. Ja, das wäre immer schön. Das ist tatsächlich etwas, was wir auch lange fordern. Ähm,
eben genau schaffen einer gesetzlichen Grundlage für zentraler Dienstleister der Sicherheitsbehörden Auf und Ausbau eigener nationaler Entwicklungsfähigkeiten und Bewertungskompetenzen bei der CITES, ja also da da geht es um Eigenentwicklung für,
Ähm na ja, Staatsdujaner letztendlich, ne? Ähm,
Dieser Teil also ähm könnte man auf jeden Fall sagen, da geht's nicht um Cybersicherheit, ne? Da geht's genau um das Gegenteil. Und das ist auch der Teil, der äh denke ich mal noch sicherlich nicht von neuen Leuten im Hause geschrieben wurde.
So, dann soll, jetzt kommen wir wieder cyber, cyber Crime und strafbare Inhalte im Internet sollen bekämpft werden.
Jetzt gucken wir uns an, was haben Sie denn da für Maßnahmen? Ja, also da wäre ja jetzt äh könnte man sich nochmal schauen, was also da wir haben ja Cybercrime,
Milliardenschäden jedes Jahr. Alles klar. Weiterer Ausbau der Abteilung Cyber Crime BK. Okay. Ausbau der zentralen Kompetenz und Servicedienstleistungen des BKA zur Bekämpfung von Cybercrime,
Also ja, BKA soll mehr in diesem Bereich äh machen,
Stärkung der internationalen Zusammenarbeit des BKA im Bereich Cybercrime unter anderem im unter anderem im Rahmen internationaler Counter Initiativen. Aha, man interessiert sich für Rensoware,
Aber Stärkung der internationalen Zusammenarbeit auch das ne ja sehr schwammig, wir wir die Geheimdienste werden's nicht mit BKA zusammenarbeiten ähm.
Wenn sie mit dem FBI oder was auch immer, ja. Förderung eines EU-weiten Rechtsrahmens zu Verhinderung und Bekämpfung des sexuellen Missbrauchs von Kindern dabei insbesondere Verhinderung der Verbreitung von Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellungen im Internet,
Das ist Chatkontrolle. Steht da nicht.
Hat ja sehr klar,
Ich war live dabei bei Markus Lanz, den Chat-Kontrollplänen einer Absage erteilt.
Im Fernsehen und auch in anderen Fernsehen drin.
Mehr mehrmals klar gesagt, dass sie diese Chatkontrolle für überzogen hält, dass sie auch mit der darüber reden möchte, selbstverständlich gleichzeitig kann sie ja nicht sich gegen die gesamte Strategie wenden, also wird da etwas kommen
Chatkontrolle steht hier nicht drin, aber,
Ne, das das stünde im nächsten Satz. Da muss man also äh da muss das Holzauge wachsam sein. Entwicklung einer nationalen Strategie zur Bekämpfung der sexuellen Gewalt gegen Kinder. Ähm,
Erstellen eines jährlichen Bundeslagebildes sexuelle Gewalt gegen Kinder. So, ich möchte nochmal sagen.
Wir reden hier von Cyber Sicherheitsstrategie, ne? Das hat also ist schon sehr weit hergeholt, dass das jetzt da ein Thema ist und warum ist das so problematisch, dass es hier mit reingenommen wird? Wir haben das auch damals oft genug besprochen hier mit Viktor und Khalisi.
Es wird der Eindruck vermittelt, dass es sich hierbei um ein um ein Cyber-Phänomen handle. Es handelt sich aber primär einmal um einen Missbrauch, der in der realen Welt stattfindet,
insofern schon sehr erstaunlich, dass wenn sie sagt, hier wir möchten Cyber Crime einschränken. Das Erste, was also erst kommt, eine internationale Zusammenarbeit in der dann kommt sexueller Kindesmissbrauch.
Personelle und technische Stärkung des BKA bei der Bekämpfung der sexuellen Gewalt gegen Kinder technisch auch wieder äh riecht nach äh Technik. Äh und dann.
Erstellung eines zentral durch das BKA koordinierten und bundesweit abgestimmten Melde- und Löschprozesses bei Missbrauchsdarstellungen im Internet.
Wäre also, wenn man's freundlich nennen möchte, wäre das der Löschen statt sperrenbereich, den das BKA.
Ja äh oder den die Polizei nicht verfolgt hat
Ja, das waren ja auch die Klagen oder die die Beschwerden, dass die löschen Löschung nicht stattgefunden haben,
Kombination mit Förderung eines EU-weiten Rechtsrahmens, sind wir aber auch gleichzeitig wieder sehr nah dran
an dieser Idee Chatkontrolle Interpol. Also das kannst du beides da reinmappen. Es ist halt zu schwammig, um das hier zu interpre,
auf jeden Fall wäre man schlecht beraten zu sagen die Chatkontrolle ist vom Eis.
Intensivere Bekämpfung strafbarer, insbesondere rechtsextremistischer Internet-Inhalte, unter anderem durch Stärkung vorhandener Strukturen beim BKA
auf äh,
Ausbau der Ermittlungsfähigkeiten der Bundespolizeientfernung im Bereich Cyberkriminalität durch personelle und technische Stärkung, konsequenter Ausbau der Zitis, um digitale Ermittlungswerkzeuge für die Sicherheitsbehörden zur Stärkung der Auswertung Analysefähigkeiten Kampf gegen Cybercons entwickel.
Halten wir fest, wenn sie also von Cyber Crime und strafbaren Inhalten im Internet reden, dann meinen sie primär ähm,
Ja ähm Kindesmissbrauch und und äh Nazis. Ähm beides große Probleme,
aber wahrscheinlich eigentlich, jetzt sage ich mal nicht unbedingt das Erste, was einem einfällt, wenn man an Cyber denkt.
Vor allem nicht cyber ich hasse dieses Wort. Nicht nicht also es ist nicht nichts Computernetzwerkspezifisches.
Genau. Genau das ist das ja und das ist äh besser kann ich's nicht sagen. Es ist nichts. Es ist es ist einfach nicht cyber.
Das ist wie wie alles irgendwie sich im Netz wiederfindet und wiederspiegelt, ja.
Komme wieder zurück zum Cyber. Ist cybersicherheit der Behörden des Bundes stärken. So, hier soll es darum gehen, dass die Behörden,
und äh staatliche Infrastrukturen besser geschützt werden. Da ist die Bundesregierung vorrangig gefordert, eine signifikante Erhöhung der Cyberresilienz,
Behörden des Bundes sicherzustellen. Der Bund muss die Schutzmaßnahmen in seiner IT-Sicherheitsarchitektur unverzüglich,
gesteigerte Bedrohungslage anpassen,
äh nahstehende Verstärkungsmaßnahmen sind unerlästig.
Gesetzliche Verankerung der Informationssicherheit und Umsetzung eines Verstärkungsplanes für Cybersicherheit des Bundes mit der Einrichtung eines Chief Information Security Officers für den Bund. Klammer auf und eines Kompetenzzentrums zur operativen Sicherheitsberatung des Bundes,
ist quasi die ne die in Unternehmen die höchste,
Verantwortliche Personen für IT-Sicherheit, für Informationssicherheit. Da heißt es doch, dass es ein schöner, alter Hacker-Begriff Information,
IT Secret. Richtig schönes.
Richtig schönes Wort. Ohne Cyber, das C, das C steht nämlich für Chief, nicht für Cyber. Will man erst, man denkt es, Eiweiß.
Aus der Häuptling.
So ähm da ist mir nur zu eingefallen wenn es das bisher nicht gab dann erklärt das auf jeden Fall einiges.
Ja, Sie können sich auch noch mal einen CTO auch noch äh zulegen. Das wäre vielleicht auch noch ganz.
CIO haben Sie ja schon. Ja, Markus, Richter heißt er, glaube ich. Ist aber nicht der von. Etablierung des Grundsatzes Security by Design and by Deforte in der Bundesverwaltung.
Ja Wahnsinn.
Dann gab's also auch noch nicht. Ausstattung der Bundeswehr mit weiterentwickelten IT-Produkten System für sichere Kommunikation sowie Investitionen in Quantencomputing und Posts, Quanten?
Kryptographie, Investigation in Investitionen in Quantencomputing beim BSI zu gewährleisten, um den sicheren Regierungskommunikation,
der Hochverfügbarkeit der Rechenzentren des Bundes, Weiterentwicklung des Informationssicherheitsmanagements.
Ja, okay, also die haben erkannt, dass sie in ihren Behörden ein äh sehr,
organisch gewachsenes äh äh Äckerchen haben und wollen da ein bisschen was reintun.
Dass man in neue äh äh Technologien investieren muss, ja ich sehe da jetzt auch nix, wo ich mich drüber aufregen müsste, ja. Cyberresilienz kritischer Infrastrukturen stärken.
Immer wieder mit diesem kritischen Infrastrukturen. Ja, ich habe das auch hier schon hundertmal erklärt. Die sind.
Bei weitem nicht so digital, wie man es sich vorstellt. Ähm ja
die laufen auf ganz katastrophal veralteter Technik und da muss es sauberes Management geben, aber
mit den kritischen Infrastrukturen hat sich schon das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz eins auseinandergesetzt und dann auch das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 2 nochmal, wo dann irgendwie die äh Unternehmen von besonderem öffentlichen Interesse.
Formuliert wurden. Die Frage ist, was soll da jetzt sein? Ähm
um bei Cybersicherheitsvorfällen schnell handlungsfähig zu sein, sollten Kritisbetreiber direkt an das BSI-Lagezentrum angebunden werden. Für jeden Kritissektor sollte da ein sektorspezifisches Cyber-Emergency-Responce-Team von den Kritis-Betreibern etabliert werden.
Vielleicht keine so schlechte Idee ja zu sagen okay wir haben jetzt ein Seat für Strom oder sonst was. Ähm.
Bisschen ja, da wird's auch am Ende sau der Schuld, dass das Ventil nicht wieder aufgeht.
Ja, das war gar nicht der Russe, der cyber war's.
So dann sagen sie okay, sie möchten Investitionen in Cyberresilienzmaßnahmen in KMU, die dem Krittessektor angehören, äh fördern, also da soll,
Soll halt die kleinen kritischen Infrastrukturen irgendwie in Resilienzmaßnahmen gefördert werden, okay,
Einrichtung von Awareness und Cyberresilienz Projekten, die vom BSI und von externen Dienstleistern angeboten werden.
Ja geil. Äh weißt du, wenn du kritische Infrastruktur bist und du hast zwei IT-Sicherheitsgesetze? Und und und 27 angekündigte CyberWars später immer noch nicht, brauchst du noch eine Wellness-Schulung, dann wird jemand.
Von von einem KMU-Unternehmen.
Berücksichtigung der Sicherheit von IT-Lieferketten im Rahmen der Kritisregulierung. Da vermute ich, dass sie das Gleiche, was sie jetzt bei den,
Mobilfunknetzen ja schon haben mit den kritischen Komponenten Komponenten, wo sie also versucht, das lese ich da rein, ja,
versuchen aus den äh Netzen rauszuhalten, in denen sie halt irgendwelche regulatorischen Auflagen machen. Da musste muss der CEO unterschreiben, dass,
keine bekannten Sicherheitslücken drin, geheim sind und auch da habe ich lange erklärt, warum es nicht die Komponente ist, sondern die,
Zusammenarbeit mit den Integratoren, aber mich hört ja keine Prüfung der Etablierung sektorspezifischer Scherz für Kritiksbetreiber und enge Ankopplungen am BSI Lagezentrum. Ja, also,
Ich bin mir sicher, dass die kritischen Infrastrukturen sich freuen, noch mehr Regulation zu bekommen und jetzt kommt,
Kommen wir endlich an der sechsten Stelle zu dem ähm zu dem Schutz ziviler Infrastrukturen, also zivile Infrastrukturen würde ich jetzt denken,
meine. Ich nehme ja am Cyberwall nicht teil, ich bin keine Behörde, also bin ich Zivilist. Zivilhack,
zivile Digitalinfrastrukturen haben eine schon wollte Allianz in Sicherheit. Ja also das scheint da so da scheine ich angesprochen zu sein.
Breitere Nutzergemeinschaft, insbesondere KMU. So und jetzt pass auf was kriegen wir? Erstens.
Wir kriegen ein BSI-Information Sharing Paul ist ein,
eine zentrale Webseite, wo sich dann die KMU informieren können.
Schreiber kommt. So und.
Dann.
Dann kriegen wir ein ziviles Cyber-Abwehrsystem,
Oder ja Sets. Das zentrale Elemente einer zivilen Netzverteidigung enthält, mit denen aktiv und automatisiert auf Cyberangriffe reagiert werden kann.
Das sind die beiden Sachen, die wir kriegen. Wir kriegen eine Webseite, wo wir gucken können und aktiv und automatisiert zivile Netzverteidigung auf Cyberangriff.
Leute wie was für eine was für eine Vorstellung von Cyber haben die? Wir wir haben jetzt aktiv aktiv muss man auch noch aufpassen aktives Cyberabwehr ja und automatisiert,
Wie stellen die sich das vor? Weißt du, wenn du die also nehmen wir wieder, weil das der häufigste Schanzer ist?
Wie sieht so ein Angriff aus? Entweder irgendjemand hat ein Teamworker oder ein Remote Desktop offen gelassen oder einen Link in einer E-Mail geklickt, dann passiert zwei Wochen gar nichts
funktioniert irgendwann mal der Drucker nicht, bis dann der Domain Admin an dem Rechner sein Passwort eingegeben hat, dann äh wird der Backup-Server abgeschossen, weil er in der Domäne hängt und dann werden alle Dateien verschlüsselt,
ein paar ab um potentieller Mütze erpressen. So, das heißt, wo ist jetzt der Aktiv automatisierte schnell,
Netzverteidigungsaspekt. Ich sehe ich verstehe nicht, wie die sich das vorstellen.
Weiß auch überhaupt nicht, also mir fällt auch gerade gar nichts ein, was was da überhaupt helfen könnte. Also denken die sich da sozusagen so eine Art Zärt, wo man dann anrufen kann, sagen kann, ich bin gehackt worden, bitte helft mir.
Bilden sich ein und ich bin ganz irrisch, wo ich das hier,
finde. Äh das ist glaube ich und in diesem Aktiv ähm,
Die bilden sich ein, dass sie, wenn denn ein richtig schwerer Angriff ist, ne,
Aber nur wenn es schwer ist, dann muss man den Server ausschalten, wo der herkommt und das hat das hörst du so in der Tagesschau.
Beim schweren Angriff. Dann dann wollen sie den ausschalten,
Das also aktives Abwehr, gut jetzt ein bisschen Spaß beiseite, besteht natürlich im im Bloggen bestimmter IP-Adressen in Blocken bestimmter äh Domänen, von denen du weißt, dass da ähm,
Schadsoftware herkommt, ja das ist also da kann man schon was machen
Ja, also ich das kann sicherlich Angriffe verhindern, wenn man weiß, okay unter folgende Domains gibt es gerade, äh äh wird gerade bereitgestellt, weil die wird ja immer nachgeladen über einen Dropper, also Excel Marco, kommen wir gleich auch noch mal zu. Ähm äh Office Micro ähm,
Jetzt kannst du natürlich sagen, okay, wir haben eine zentrale DNS-Infrastruktur mit einer Blockliste, die versucht sicherzustellen, dass halt,
Schatz auf fair, verbreitende Domänen gesperrt werden, vielleicht auch IP-Adressen gesperrt werden, die bekannt sind kann man schon auch positiv sehen,
Was ich nicht sehe, ist, boah, da ist sein so ein starkes da müssen wir jetzt da, da fahren wir aber jetzt ins Rechenzentrum, machen den Server aus.
Das ist ja das, was Sie sich so vorstellen. Das ist auch das, was natürlich der Gesellschaft so verkauft wird. Ja, ja natürlich. Wenn da so, wenn da so ein so ein cybericher Server steht, der so stark ist,
Da muss man aber der Staat auch mal einfach.
Machen, ja. Es es steht da leider so eine eine nicht also das trifft halt nicht das, wie Angreifer, vorgehen, Angreiferinnen vorgehen, die Sache, die ich hier klar sehe, ist.
Im schwierigen Bereich, weil wir im Bereich der sind und so weiter. Ja,
Natürlich kann man sich eine und das nutze ich ja auch, ich nutze ja für meinen selbst souverän in meinen DNS-Servern auch Speerlisten, dass sich bestimmte Domains im Zweifelsfall nicht auflöse,
die äh,
die ich nicht äh wo ich wo's mir lieber wäre, wenn meine Rechner sich da nicht hinverbinden. Aber man muss sich natürlich auch überlegen, dass das nicht sonderlich äh zielführend ist.
Weil als ich mit Thorsten damals 2016 oder was oder 2015 sogar diesen 1ten weitverbreiteten Brandsong Royal analysiert habe, ähm der hatte so eine Domain-Generation ähm,
Algorithmus. Funktioniert also so. Der der würfelt sich quasi,
aus dem Datum und einem Random Seed einen Domainnamen, den er versucht, wenn sein Primärdomänen nicht funktioniert. Also wenn du ihm den DNS sperrst, fängt der.
Irgendeine Domäne aus und auf der anderen Seite weiß man auch, welche das jetzt zu welchem Zeitpunkt ist.
Und das sind und wenn die nicht funktioniert, dann versucht er die Nächste. Und so geht der Tausende durch. Also du hast einfach so ein random Generator?
Bisschen wie diese second äh wo dein Device sozusagen alle 15 Sekunden eine andere Zahl anzeigt und auf der anderen Seite weißt du halt auch, welche Zahl da angezeigt wird und dann kannst du direkt darauf äh.
Und wenn du jetzt, wenn du den wirklich abschießen möchtest, musst du alle diese Domain sperren. Du musst also viele hunderttausend Domains jeden Tag sperren, damit der nicht funktioniert und der und es es ist quasi natürlich dadurch, dass das Rolling ist, ist es de facto endlos.
Hilft nur beschränkt, sagen wir's mal so.
Es hilft nur beschränkt, genau.
Das ist also die Sicherheitsagenda oder hast noch ein.
Ne Moment, ne? Wir waren jetzt bei sechs, jetzt kurze sieben.
Oder wie viel Gips.
Acht. Digitalsouveränität in der Cybersicherheit stärken. Jetzt haben wir diesen Begriff der digitalen Souveränität wird ja auch von vielen kritisiert. Ähm sehe ich nicht so kritisch. Klingt ein bisschen doof, aber müssen die Sachen ja net. Das ist im Prinzip alles so
deutsches halber Sicherheitsforschung
kriegt mehr Geld, Kommunikationstechnologien, 5G6G soll mehr Geld kriegen, äh
Prüfmöglichkeiten des BSI ähm für kritische Komponenten sollen erhöht werden.
Und ähm innovative Forschungsformen. Also insgesamt, da ist so dieser wir investieren jetzt mal in ähm in äh Forschung.
Und dann wollen sie noch die äh,
krisenfeste Kommunikationsfähigkeit schaffen, äh uns das wird ja auch wieder voll sie wollen dem die den weit die Weitverkehrsnetze,
gemäß der Netzstrategie 201330 für die öffentliche Verwaltung modernisieren. Ähm sie wollen die Behörden, das wird dir gefallen, Tim, zentrale Unterstützung der Behörden bei der Einführung von IP V sechs.
Oh Mann, Alpti vor sechs. Ich weiß noch, wann ich meinen ersten Vortrag habe auf IPV sechs aufm Kongress gehalten habe. Das war,
Ich weiß es gerade nicht mehr. Lasse mich kurz nachdenken. Das muss,
hundert ähm das muss irgendwie,
vierundneunzig.
Sein, ja. Na ja, dann wollen Sie äh da geht's ja Einführung eines zentralen Videokonferenzsystems für die Bundesverwaltung Modernisierung des Digitalfunknetzes für Behörden,
Einrichtung einer Breitbandkommunikation im Digitalfunknetz, ja, okay, da wollen Sie ein bisschen Infrastrukturinvestitionen machen ähm ja.
Jetzt fragt man sich mal, was was wären denn so Forderungen gewesen, die wir sonst noch hatten, ne? Wie wär's einfach mit Produkthaftung?
War ja immer, also ich denke mal vielleicht ein bisschen meine Perspektive. IT-Sicherheit wird ähm tendiert dazu, kaputtreguliert zu werden, weil den Leuten nichts besseres einfällt, als mit irgendwelchen Checklisten daher zu kommen.
Unternehmen, jetzt mach mal einen Audit, jetzt haben wir hier Iso 27001 audit, wir müssen fünfundachtzig, hundert Kreuze machen,
Wenn da eins nicht ist, dann hast du ein Auditfeinding, dann musst du es anders machen, weil du hier nicht den weil du den falschen Schlüssel verwendest. Das ist es führt kein führt hier keinen weiter. IT-Sicherheit muss leider nun mal dynamisch.
Äh gemacht werden und äh so verstehe ich das eben auch im beruflich. Ja, dass du kannst nicht sagen, ja wir haben hier irgendwie so einen Standard und wenn du den jetzt erfüllst, dann bist du sicherer. Du musst dir überlegen, was macht dieses Unternehmen
will das erreichen? Welche Angriffsflächen sind dafür notwendig und wie gehe ich mit denen um? Und wie was sind die Risiken für dieses Unternehmen? Kleiner Hind,
alle Dateienverschlüsse ist für die meisten Unternehmen durchaus ein Risiko so äh wie begegnen wir dem? Machen wir einen Plan, stellen wir uns darauf, stellen wir uns dafür auf, dass wir eben den,
Den Notfall nicht zu Disaster werden lassen. Das IT-Sicherheit. So und,
Das muss kannst das beste Ziel ist, sieh bitte zu, dass der Geschäftsbetrieb aufrecht erhalten werden kann,
kann man dafür natürlich Empfehlungen geben, ja und dann gibt's auch natürlich Best Practices und so weiter. Aber.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel einfach sagt, okay, pass auf, du hast ein IT-System hier beim Verkauf für viel, viel Geld,
Du haftest dafür, wenn das Ding irgendwie äh Schwachstellen hat, die diesem Unternehmen einen größeren Schaden zufügen. Du haftest dafür, wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Du haftest dafür, dass du Security bei Design Security bei Defauld hast.
Nicht nicht sinnvollen Standards genügt, sinnvollen Best Practices, sinnvollen Stand der Technik oder eben klar einfach Schwachstellen hat, dann bist du schuld,
Und dann kannst du dafür Haftfolger gemacht hast. Meinst du, wie schnell sich in den IT-Buden auf einmal,
Development Lifecycles etablieren und irgendwie Coding Practices und so weiter und und auf einmal halt
ganze Bload und Legacy aus dem ganzen Scheiß rauskommt. Wenn die wenn die für das Problem, was sie da schaffen, am Ende auch noch haften würden,
Würde ganz schnell gehen und zwar könntest du das der Dynamik des Marktes überlassen. Das geht ganz schnell.
Einfach so. Einfach so. Aber was ich jetzt nicht verstehe ist.
Update.
Warum steht da jetzt nix äh mit Blockchain? Also.
Sei froh, ey, sei froh, dass er einzig Gute.
Ich dachte so sollen alle Probleme lösen.
Dann äh so dann natürlich also Produkthaftung und Updateszwang, ne, diese also beziehungsweise ähm,
Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum sind so die beiden Forderungen, die wir jetzt die ganze Zeit haben. Ähm.
Es ist jetzt nicht der große Wurf ähm,
Das ist man kann das jetzt auch nicht wirklich mit
mit einmalig Befugnissen und Geld vergießen. Risiken sehe ich natürlich bei irgendwie den den potenziellen Ausstattung von äh BKA, Citis, äh BFV, äh deren
Äh wie wie Werte, wie nennen die es immer, Befugnisse, ne? Oder die nennen es Kompetenzen und Befugnisse?
Meinen damit aber natürlich eigentlich äh Grundrechtseinschränkungen. Das äh da da kann man nochmal schauen, was da kommt. Da werden wir also auch in diesem äh in dieser Legislaturperiode nicht verschont bleiben.
Dann äh gab es jetzt in meiner Wahrnehmung einige Leute, die es mit diesem Server herunterfahren äh interpretiert haben als Hackback,
Das lese ich da noch nicht raus. Ich lese da nicht offensive Fähigkeiten für äh für für diesen Fall. Nancy Feeser sagt auch immer, dass die Heckback ablehnt,
Ähm das, was hier mit aktiver Cyber-Abwehr gemeint ist, verstehe ich,
Als äh DNS-Sperren eventuell IP-Sperren, es liest sich hier noch nach freiwillig und,
mit diesem Server herunterfahren. Äh ich bin mal gespannt, welcher Hacker so doof ist,
Einen Server in einem in einer Juristion zu betreiben, wo Nancy Phaser ultimativ die Macht hat, den Ausscheider zu drücken,
Und ihre Angriffe so strukturieren, dass das tatsächlich durch das Ausschalten eines Servers alles vermasselt ist so. Boah, wir hatten voll die geile Hacking-Kampagne, die war so oh nein, ihr seid nicht selber ausgemacht. Jetzt äh oh,
Jetzt können wir die Software nicht auf einen anderen deployen und einfach weitermachen.
Haben die ausgemacht, die Schweine, ey.
Die Vorstellung, dass irgendwie Dinge nur noch auf einem Server passieren oder ein einziger Server äh etwas aus dem Tritt bringen kann, die ist halt alt.
Das war klar. Das war übrigens auch zu diesem Thema. Also Tagesschau kriegt man ja relativ viele Fragen, aber genau diesen Aspekt, das war dann auch das, was sie äh in die Sendung genommen haben. Ich dachte so, ich kam mir jetzt schwer vorstellen, dass es noch angreifenden gibt, die sich so
ungeschickt äh verhalten.
Ich habe mal geguckt, was dieser Herr Markus Richter äh der Beauftragte der Bundesregierung für Informationstechnik,
ähm was den eigentlich so qualifiziert und ähm na ja also er ist Jurist.
Tätigkeiten umfassten Personalwesen, Organisation des Büro des Präsidenten sowie Grundsatzfragen, Integration und Migration äh als er irgendwie sich beim BAMF äh beschäftigt hat,
Dann ist er irgendwann Abteilungsleiter für Infrastruktur und IT geworden.
Ja also das das erklärt dann ein bisschen, warum hier so viel drin steht, wer alles mehr Geld kriegt und äh größere Organisationen, ne? Das äh kann das erklären.
Ah, hier steht noch ein Grund. Er ist Mitglied in der CDU.
Ich habe ja gesagt, dass das wäre, das hätte ich Nancy Phasers erster Arbeitstag. Wer von euch hat denn ein Parteibuch? Zeigt mal, was für eins. Geht mal.
Na ja gut, also ich finde das jetzt nicht generell verwerflich äh aber,
ich hätte jetzt, also weil du vorhin meintest, wir haben ja ein CIO,
und äh dachte ich so aha okay welche kompetente Person haben Sie da rein? Normalerweise ist es halt auch wieder eine rein politische Figur,
Also es ist sozusagen eine,
Eine politische Tätigkeit und man würde ja hier eher jemanden erwarten, also ich in meinem immer noch jugendlichen Leichtsinn, äh der erwartet, dass sich hier äh vielleicht jemand wiederfinden würde, der in irgendeiner Form,
seit langer Zeit in diesen Security-Dingen äh unterwegs ist. Aber das ist just me. So bin ich halt. Mit meinem Optimismus und all dem Kram.
Ich
ich kann jetzt da auch nicht viel zu sagen, ja, das ist natürlich wär's sinnvoll, äh jemanden zu haben, der sich da auch technisch mit auseinandersetzt, gleichzeitig ist es natürlich auch ein organisatorisches Problem. Insofern ist das nicht
wahrscheinlich nicht so verkehrt, wenn man da auch jemanden hat, der mit Organisationsstrukturen.
Okay, das äh okay, meinetweg.
Aber äh.
Und es ist auch schon mal gut, dass es an sich die Stelle gibt, so weil sonst hätte man gar keine.
Oh, der kriegt ja jetzt bei dazu. Chiefinformation Officer.
Na gut.
Also insgesamt kein kein großer Wurf mit den mit dem Ausbau der ähm der mittelunfähigkeiten für Strafverfolgungsbehörden und Geheimdienste wahr zu rechnen. Ähm,
Man kann sicherlich auch sagen, dass beide nicht ähm nennenswert,
gut funktionieren, ja, aber was sich hier, was hier die klaffende Lücke ist, eben.
Was gibt es heute für brennende Probleme in der IT-Sicherheit, die unmittelbaren Handlungsbedarf zeigen und was wird dagegen unternommen und da ist das Ding halt ziemlich blank. Okay.
Gut. Dann machen wir mit einem anderen Thema weiter.
Wir hatten es damals schon äh angekündigt Services sind ja jetzt in äh digital Markets Acts in ähm,
Kraft getreten und wer wer beschwert sich drüber, sichere Messenger Frema und Signal sind gegen Interoperabilität, ja? Klar, äh WhatsApp soll ja dazu gezwungen werden, Nachrichten von kleineren,
Messengern empfangen zu können. Das war die Idee. Wir haben damals auch hier mit dem äh.
Patrick Breier.
Patrick Breier darüber gesprochen und von Edri, Jan Penrat drüber gesprochen, heißt es Thema, ja, also der Grundgedanke ist, WhatsApp hat so eine große Marktmacht, das ist eigentlich kein anderer Messenger überhaupt mehr konkurrieren kann aufgrund des Netzwerkeffektes, deswegen soll WhatsApp gezwungen werden
eine einheitliche Schnittstelle zur Anbindung anderer Messenger,
anzubieten, sodass es denen erleichtert wird, in den Markt einzutreten. Das ist sicherlich eine sehr ehrenvolle Idee.
Äh weil die großen Anbieter ja eben auch durch ihre Marktmacht die diese weiter ausbauen. Ähm.
Aber wenn du jetzt unterschiedliche Verschlüsselungsmechanismen hast, zwischen beispielsweise Threema und ähm WhatsApp, WhatsApp benutzt die gleiche Verschlüsselung wie Signal, ähnliche,
Dann musst du jetzt irgendwie etwas schaffen, dass ein Signalnutzer äh oder ein Threemanutzer mit einem WhatsApp Nutzer äh sinnvoll kommunizieren kann mit der gleichen Sicherheit und ich habe ja hier öfter gesagt, das geht nicht.
Dann kamen Leute, haben gesagt, mit Matrix wird das alles gelöst, da gibt's äh irgendwelche,
eleganten Lösungen, die habe ich auch bei mir selber gehostet in der Version null drei. Das mag alles sein,
nein es ja also das mag ja sein aber die Frage ist skaliert das?
Und äh ja Threema hat äh sofort gesagt Sicherheitsbedenken,
an dieser Stelle, bei anderen Messengern fallen dann auf einmal Metadaten an, die bei uns nicht anfallen. Durchgängige Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung ist nicht möglich. Die sind einfach inkompatibel.
Weil die Nachricht eben beim Übergang zu einem anderen Messenger entschlüsselt werden müssen und ähm,
Liegen halt auch die Identitäten an andere Messenger. Also sagen die jetzt quasi und das sind ja eigentlich die, die genau die, die sie damit stärken wollten. Sind die Ersten, die ihr einfallen?
Sagen äh äh freuen wir dich. Und Telegram wird wahrscheinlich sagen wie verschlüsselt? Haben wir nicht.
Das ist äh ist dann doch so verlaufen, äh wie wir's äh.
Man wundert sich, warum die sich jetzt erst melden.
Ja, ich meine, ja, das ist auch die Frage, ja.
Ja, hören die unsere Sendung nicht oder was? Also da schicken wir mal eine Beschwerde hin. Aber,
Das ist halt, ich meine, wir haben ja vor allem aus einer wir hatten ja die Diskussion mit,
und er hat es halt aus einer,
gut gemeinten politischen Perspektive heraus argumentiert und so verstehe ich ja auch diesen ganzen Ansatz. So, das ist ja irgendwie gut gemeint so und wir haben ja aus einer,
technischen Perspektive heraus äh argumentiert,
auch nicht unbedingt immer die die volle Wahrheit in sich äh trägt, nur in dem Moment, wo man halt wirklich über Verschlüsselungen und Interoperitäten, also sprich,
Internetkommunikation,
reden. Sind diese technischen Realitäten natürlich nicht ganz unerheblich und äh klar, man kann technische Realitäten auch anpassen, aber das bedeutet in dem Fall eben, dass Systeme ihre Sicherheit aufgeben müssen, weil sie ihre Kiffige quasi öffnen müssen. Ähm,
obwohl das sozusagen gerade bei Streamer in gewisser Hinsicht auch bei Single natürlich,
das ist das ist die Idee, dass es sozusagen der Grund, warum man das benutzt ist, dass es.
Ja
Das also da ist der Käfig, der Sicherheitstechnik-Käfig da auch nicht geöffnet, sondern in sich geschlossen sein, in sich geschlossenes Konzept hat, ne. Also bei Frima, also wenn ihr vielleicht jetzt nicht alle hm benutzen, da ist man erstmal,
Niemand, sondern da ist man irgendwie nur so ein sechs Buchstaben Zahlencode.
Und man kann dann selber äh entscheiden, inwiefern man da seine Anonymität äh aufgibt und ähm auch wenn das, sagen wir mal so, für das ähm,
Aufsetzen äh dann doch auch seine Nachteile hat, ganz klar, ne? Umso mehr du verschlüsselst, umso schwieriger machst du's natürlich auch erstmal am Anfang.
Hat das eben auch zahlreiche Vorteile. Wenn ich mir anschaue in wie viel Singlegruppen ich jetzt irgendwie aufgenommen werde,
ja und meine Telefonnummer sozusagen ungefragt,
in die Welt äh gespuckt wird. Da habe ich dann auch schon so ein bisschen meine äh
bedenken, aber wenn sozusagen jetzt auch noch äh der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner aller Messenger untereinander äh der Standard werden soll, dann dann wird alles noch viel schlimmer.
Also das ist alles nicht wünschenswert und meiner Meinung nach auch
technisch nicht durchführbar. Das müssen wir jetzt nicht alles nochmal wiederholen. Da haben wir sehr, sehr, sehr ausführlich in irgendeiner Sendung, die wir vielleicht nicht an uns schreiben, wenn wir sie finden. Ähm uns schon zu geäußert.
Wie gesagt, die mit Jan Penfrath damals glaube ich auf jeden Fall diskutiert.
Ich glaube wir hatten auch noch eine Sendung, wo wir das unter uns diskutiert haben, ja ja unter uns.
Ne? Unter uns. Unter uns gleichem gleichgemeinten. So dann haben wir äh also ja da haben wir wieder Recht gehabt. So dann äh.
Das ist ja das Wichtigste überhaupt.
Office Markros werden jetzt doch nicht deaktiviert. Also wir haben's ja hier gefeiert, dass Microsoft gesagt hat, okay, wenn,
Wenn eine Datei aus dem Internet heruntergeladen wurde, dann deaktivieren wir automatisch die Makros. Und,
Jetzt hat Microsoft gesagt, ah, nee, machen wir doch nicht. Und ich ich wenn wenn du,
Eine Datei aus dem Internet runterlädst mit Markus und die ausführst,
in irgendeiner Form kritisch für deine Geschäftsprozesse ist, dann solltest du dich darauf vorbereiten, bald
nicht mehr tätig zu sein. So und es ist es muss abgeschaltet sein. Und jetzt hat Microsoft hat gesagt, sie sie rollen das wieder zurück, also mit dem nächsten Update ist es wieder an. Was auch wieder so die,
die fürchterlichste Idee ist, wie du äh wie du agieren kannst, ja, dass du sagst,
Hier wir wir lösen das Problem endlich nach 25 Jahren. Alle denken, oh ehrlich geil geil und dann sagst du so nee doch nicht. Also es ist katastrophal. Entsprechend haben wir auch eine
Anleitung verlinkt, wie man dieses Feature wieder aktiviert. Ich rate allen dazu,
allen Unternehmen, an Privatpersonen, allen unter der Sonne Markus,
ganz grundsätzlich zu deaktivieren, nicht zu nutzen ähm nein,
Nein und vor allem Vorsicht, das müsst ihr in Office äh in, in Excel, in Word und ich glaube sogar im Powerpoint gibt's auch Makros.
Also man kann die schon nutzen, man sollte sie bloß nicht nutzen, wenn die Dokumente von jemand anders kommen.
Ich würde es, aber das ist genau das ist genau das Problem. Da kommt euch dann diese Warnung, wo drauf steht, Sicherheitswarnung Markus akquiriert, so ein riesiger Knopf, wo du dann drauf drückst und das ist der zum Aktivieren des Mak,
Rechts oben in der kleinen Ecke sind Klaus kleines, graues Kreuz, was der,
Finger weg vom Markus nicht machen, nicht machen.
Ich würde ja sagen, Finger weg von Microsoft, aber ich glaube, da ja komme ich nicht durch.
Ja, das ist das ist das ist also wenn ihr sicher sein wollt, deinstalliert ihr das einfach, aber.
Ich bin überhaupt der Einzige, den ich kenne, der kein Excel benutzt.
Ja weil du auch du auch nicht professionell arbeitest, Tim. Du du machst da irgendwie fünf Zahlen in in in oder so und denkst du hättest jetzt irgendwie ein.
Ja. Genau. Aber ich halte es durch.
Ja mit fünf Zahlen hat man früher mitm Stift ein Blatt Papier gemacht.
Stiftung Blatt Papier sogar.
Wahrscheinlich bei Nambas musst du wahrscheinlich auch nachher noch an der Seite rechnen, weil.
Ich benutze auch kein Wirt. Und kein PowerPoint.
Es ist alles eine Geißel, aber ich komme leider beruflich nicht drumherum.
Ja ja ich weiß, die Zwänge und so. Passt schon.
Ich benutze äh.
Und PowerPoint und wenn ich also wenn ich private Vorträge mache eher Keynote aber im beruflichen Rahmen,
PowerPoint tatsächlich auch. Also ich ich finde auch PowerPoint man kann bessere Sachen mit Powerpoint machen als sein Ruf ist.
PowerPoint noch durchgehen. Excel verwirrt mich äh wird,
beleidigt mich. Also das das ist einfach das das geht als das geht überhaupt nicht in meinem Leben.
Problem bei all diesen drei Tools ist, dass sie.
Verbreitet sind.
Nee, die sinnvollen Funktionen weit verstecken. Ja, also ich kriege schon immer eine Krise, wenn irgendjemand in in wenn ich ein Word-Dokument kriege,
wo jemand nach jedem Absatz zweimal Enter drückt. Das macht man nicht, man geht in die Formatvorlage und sagt sechs Punkte Abstand unter dem Paragraph.
Ja
Ja? Aber,
Taste ist halt näher dran und dann fangen die Leute an und machen irgendwie die Überschriften, jede Überschrift fett und dann fällt ihnen irgendwie ein Ei. Jetzt will sie auch noch haben, dann müsste,
Nein, man ändert die Formatverlangen. Aber äh und äh das Gleiche ist bei PowerPoint, die sinnvollen Funktionen von PowerPoint sind im siebten in der siebten Unterebene des Menüs,
Deswegen sieht auch alles scheiße aus, was die Leute. Okay, lassen wir das jetzt also.
Also Microsoft Word30 war geil. Das fand ich richtig, richtig geil.
Wo so ein Füller. Nee, das war Wort sechs, ne, wohl so ein ich glaube.
Ich rede von,
als es noch kein gab. In den achtziger Jahren Microsoft war so mit auf Textbildschirm und so weiter. Das war wirklich richtig,
irgendwie seitdem dieses Windows dazu gekommen ist, weil das alles überhaupt nicht mehr zu ertragen. Also da habe ich komplett Abstand genommen davon.
Das ist glaube ich der das ist sowieso das Problem.
Eine kurze kurze heftige Liebelei, die wir äh miteinander hatten, aber es war dann auch schnell vorbei und 10 hat alles beendet und danach wollte ich von Microsoft,
nie wieder nie wieder hören. Und es ist so,
ich benutze A ich habe Skype benutzt, ich gebe es zu, aber die sind ja auch gekauft worden und äh für.
Haben wir uff.
Schulische Dinge ist jetzt ab und zu sogar erforderlich dieses Teams zu starten. Ja ja, aber äh na ja, egal. Äh,
Hast schon recht. Ich äh nehme mir da etwas heraus, was was äh sich eigentlich keiner herausnehmen kann.
Teams kann man also lassen wir jetzt nicht nicht also Office deaktivieren und fertig. Äh dann haben wir äh jetzt gibt's einen Brief,
von EU-Abgeordneten, die sich an die gute Margarete Festtage äh.
Bestimmt, oder? Ist das französisch oder belgisch?
Weiß nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Egal. Wir wissen alle, was gemeint ist. Bis da.
Gucke gerade hier in der Wikipedia.
Okay.
Ich weiß nicht, was Doppelpunkt mit so einem komischen drunter.
Zeigt wie wie viel wir Sachen einfach nur im Internet lesen, wenn man dann nicht mal einmal die ist doch wahrscheinlich alle drei Tage im Fernsehen, der wird doch irgendwann mal jemand den Namen gesagt haben.
Äh ja aber vielleicht nicht richtig.
Okay, sie hat angekündigt, sie möchte äh große Online-Dienste wie YouTube, Netflix für ihren Datentransfer extra zur Kasse bitten.
Damit die Provider dafür,
Telekom und Telefonica sollen dann eben an den Profiten der IT-Branche mitnaschen, schreibt Thomas Rudower Netz für Tick Org und fordern einen fairen Anteil ein
äh scharfe Kritik. Ich glaube Thomas hatte auch schon darüber gesprochen
Jetzt haben also 54 Abgeordnete mit äh so also aus dem liberalen Bereich links-grün ähm gefordert,
darüber überhaupt mal diskutiert wird, ja ähm also Patrick Breier, Cornelia Ernst, Alexandra Gese, Helmut Scholz,
Birgit Zippel und Timo Wölken, unter anderem insgesamt vierundfünfzig.
Also sagt hier bevor jetzt die Netzneutralität aufhebt ähm wär's ganz schön äh wenn man äh
sich damit mal wirklich auseinandersetzt, ja und,
möchten eben, dass hier eine Konsultation,
stattfindet und dass diese,
möglichst breit mit der Zivilgesellschaft und Regulierungsbehörden stattfindet ähm und das ist sicherlich sehr,
Also es ist hier wieder scheint wieder so äh ich sage mal, hier leuchtet die Breierleuchte, ne? Der hat uns jahrelang vor der Chatkontrolle gewarnt und man dachte immer, komm ey,
Mein Hobby oder so, ja, weil das so so unvorstellbar komisch und irre war, vor vor was der da die ganze Zeit gewarnt hat, dass man dachte, damit kommen die doch nie durch. Und jetzt sagt er, ja, die wollen
mehr oder weniger jetzt auf der anderen Seite des Internets äh plötzlich.
Netzneutralität killen.
Killen und äh da muss man vorsichtig sein. So hoffen wir, dass wir da also weil und der Thomas hat uns ja auch schon gewarnt, also da müssen wir gucken, da müssen wir die Augen aufhalten.
Dann ist vor einem Jahr die Verfassungsschutznovelle in Kraft getreten. Ähm die hatten wir hier natürlich auch behandelt, dass wir die, wo äh auf einmal alle 17 Geheimdienste, Inlandsgeheimdienste der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, Staatstrojaner benutzen dürfen.
Ohne Richtervorbehalt und wie sie wollen und da gibt es jetzt eine äh Verfassungsbeschwerde von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, ähm,
die also argumentiert, da hier kein Richtervorbehalt, da es Geheimdienste sind und so, sind schwere Grundrechtseingriffe vorprogrammiert. Wir wenden uns dagegen, ähm die Anabiselli ist eine der Beschwerdeführerinnen von Netzbetik Och, die äh Chefredakteurin.
Und hat äh dazu auch einen Kommentar geschrieben, warum das äh eben ein großes äh Problem ist, ein anderer äh ist Jean-Peters, Journalist und Aktionskünstler beim Kollektiv und äh die haben sich jetzt also dieser,
die haben jetzt diese Verfassungsbeschwerde eingereicht und
Ich glaube, es war in der Anhörung zu dem Gesetz, hatte André Meiß da so ein bisschen protokolliert, dass der Jurist Becker sagte, ja, ist ja eigentlich gut, wenn er das mal beschließt, weil dann kann man's endlich mal vom Bundesverfassungsgericht klären, aber besser, noch besser wäre natürlich, wenn ihr das sein lässt. Die äh Anwältin
Seda Bashay Yildiz, die äh vom NSU zwei Punkt null da äh bedroht wurde, ist auch unter der Beschwerdeführerin, ja,
Das wir wissen das dauert jetzt wieder jahrelang, aber ist gut, dass er's gemacht.
Ja, sinnvoll.
Dann hätten wir noch eine ich sage mal eher so ein kurzes Thema, ne. Also es soll auch das ist natürlich jetzt irgendwie schwierig die EU möchte,
dass man nicht möchte, die Möglichkeiten einschränken, anonym an Kryptogeld zu kommen und,
ich kann den die Bestrebung verstehen,
Ähm vor allem, wenn da so viel Kriminalität mit herrscht und vor allem auch so viel äh ja Geld, Steuerhinterziehung naheliegt, ja, äh dass dass sie also möchten, dass eigentlich niemand mehr,
Das alles, was öffentlich irgendwie an Exchanges ist, registriert ist und dass die Exchanges, die mit anonymen Rollets äh arbeiten, irgendwie gebrandmarkt werden.
Ähm Patrick Breier positioniert sich dagegen, weil damit eben die anonymen Zahlungen für Individuen ähm,
Eingeschränkt werden sollen und das ist, ne, darum geht es. Ich persönlich habe mir da noch nicht die finale äh äh Meinung zu.
Geschaffen, weil ich eigentlich schon den Eindruck habe, dass ähm,
ja ich mit mit meinen Möglichkeiten Bargeld auszugeben,
anonym bin, vielleicht hat er hier die bessere ähm Weitsicht, was
die Bedeutung von Zahlungsverkehr im Internet in Zukunft noch bedeuten wird. Vielleicht denkt er auch daran, dass es äh hier irgendwann alles Web 3 ist und dann,
Gleichzeitig ist es jetzt schon so, dass anonyme,
Zahlungsmittel im Weitverkehr in großen Summen jetzt nicht unbedingt mhm besonders positiver Wertbeitrag zur Demokratie und Gesellschaft sind.
Ich würde mich mit dem Thema nochmal in in Ruhe befassen, beziehungsweise es wird jetzt auch noch mal weiter diskutiert werden, also,
ist es immer schlecht, wenn Anonymität verboten wird. Ja, gleichzeitig ist es ist die Idee von Bitcoin, dass du dein Wallet selber hast und selber machst und,
das können die gar nicht verbieten. Ich mache mir jetzt einen Bitcoin und ich werde niemandem sagen, dass es meins ist und das können die jetzt auch nicht weißt du?
Na ja, also hier geht's ja sozusagen dadrum also wen das betreffen würde, ne? Es würde äh,
diese ganzen Börsen mhm. Betreffen, weil,
Klar kann man theoretisch in der Krypto-Geldwelt äh alles unabhängig davon machen,
Das Allermeiste läuft,
diese Plattform und das auch aus gutem Grund, weil einfach kaum jemand bereit ist äh permanent zum Beispiel die ganze Blockchain vorzuhalten äh et cetera. Klar, da gibt's dann irgendwie tausend irgendwelche
komischen Wallet äh äh Lösung, womit du das dann irgendwie auf deinem Telefon machen kannst, aber
führt letzten Endes immer nur dazu, dass du dann doch noch in irgendeiner Form an einer App, an irgendeinem externen Dienst dran hängst
der letzten Ende sicherstellt, dass deine Zahlung halt konform ist mit diesem Gesamtblockchain-Gewölk. Und.
Das hier ist ja sozusagen die Miniversion von also die Alternative wäre gewesen, lass uns den Scheiß irgendwie mal komplett äh verbieten, weil der nervt uns eigentlich nur noch,
die Traute haben sie halt derzeit noch nicht, weil natürlich jetzt auch eine ganze Menge
Lobbyismus da im Hintergrund stattfindet, der eben sagt, so nee, nee, das ist irgendwie immer noch alles total die Zukunft und wollte nicht die ihr wollt doch sicherlich nicht die Innovation
verbieten und dann werdet ihr komplett abgehängt. Also es gibt immer noch diese Vorstellung davon, es würde sich bei dieser Blockchain um irgendwas total
geiles, äh wichtiges Handeln, dass wenn man das jetzt irgendwie sein lässt, dass man irgendwie abgehängt wird.
Ich meine, ist ja nachvollziehbar, dass äh unsere,
politische Klasse äh das Gefühl hat äh abgehängt zu sein, weil sie's ja sind.
Ja, es ist ja sozusagen, dass wir das den den technologischen Entwicklungen laufen wir ja tatsächlich weitgehend hinterher
Ja, also was Internetausbau äh betrifft, ja, IP V sechs soll jetzt mal eingeführt werden. Warum ist die 498 mein Vortrag? Aber egal. Ähm,
all diese ganzen Dinge laufen halt äh schlecht, besonders in Deutschland,
Ja, über Internetausbau müssen wir hier gar nicht erst wieder äh anfangen, einfach weil man überhaupt nicht verstanden hat
Die ganze Dimension von dem Ganzen ist, was irgendwie wichtig ist, wie man da vorgehen sollte und auch wie man diese Märkte reguliert und diese ganze Kryptogeschichte überrollt jetzt irgendwie alles und weil da so viel Geld drinsteckt von einzelnen, die jetzt wahrscheinlich auch extrem
Druck äh ausüben äh sehen sie halt einfach auch überhaupt nicht, worum es sich nämlich dabei wirklich handelt, nämlich im Wesentlichen einfach um.
Betrug Wesentlichen, also es äh in meiner Perspektive und von daher ähm,
Bin ich generell für Regulierung? Ja äh einfach um,
diese Eigendynamik in diesem Bereich und das hohe Betrugspotential äh irgendwie in den Griff kriegen zu können.
Weil das findet da halt äh statt.
Immer wieder nur empfehlen hier äh das Blog, ja, wo einfach also man muss sich das einfach mal klarmachen, was in diesem sogenannten Finanzsystem.
Täglich für Scams ablaufen. Also wir reden hier nicht von da ist mal was bei einer Bank schiefgelaufen, sondern da wird einfach täglich im Bereich von
Milliarden und hunderten von Millionen
abgezogen, gescannt, brechen irgendwie Systeme zusammen. Der ganze Krypto-Cash wäre am Anfang ja schon äh wieder Scherze gemacht über den Kurs. Also da wird gerade massiv Geld vernichtet und zwar wird vor allem das Geld von Leuten vernichtet, die einfach
da reingezogen worden sind durch flashy Werbung und irgendwelche blöden äh Prominenten und Sportler und so weiter, die ihren NLT-Scheiß äh anpreisen
Wird halt alles nur gemacht, um einfach noch genug zu finden, die jetzt noch bereit sind, da Kohle reinzudrücken, damit all die Leute, die die ganze Zeit eben diese äh diese Assets, die sie da erworben haben, versilbern zu können, dass sie noch zum Zug kommen
Und da macht sich schon in gewisser Hinsicht eine gewisse Panik breit. Ich lenke jetzt ein bisschen vom eigentlichen Thema äh ab, aber wie geht's da auch eher ums Generelle, ja?
Jetzt hier wirklich Anonymität noch eine große Rolle spielt so. Ich denke, man muss hier vor allem äh regulieren, um zu verhindern, dass die Leute noch weiter über den Tisch gezogen werden und
kann das durchaus auch ein Mittel sein, weil letzten Endes geht's ja hier nur da drum, äh.
Diese ganzen Räuberbanden, die da unterwegs sind irgendwie auf den selben Level zu stellen
wie äh das normale Finanzsystem und wenn die weil wenn sie behaupten ja immer sie wären ja im Finanzsystem, da sollen sich ja auch bitte an diese Hemdenregeln halten und dann werden sie halt schon sehen, dass das irgendwie alles
einmal nicht mehr funktionieren wird in dem Moment, wo sie sich halt äh auch einfach mal der geltenden Gesetzeslage unterwerfen zu haben.
Also ich ich zitiere jetzt einfach mal, Patrick Breier, ja, aus seiner äh PM nur um dir die Gegenposition zu haben. Diese Regeln sollen gesetzestreuen Bürger ihre finanziellen Freiheit berauben, zum Beispiel sind Oppositionelle wie Alexei Nawalny zunehmend auf anonyme Spenden in virtuellen Währungen angewiesen.
Banken haben in der Vergangenheit auch Spenden an WikiLeaks blockiert. Ja ja,
Es ist äh allerdings noch sehr lange her. Mit der schleichenden Abschaffung von realem und virtuellem Bargeld drohen Negativzinsen
eine jederzeitige Abschaltung der Geldversorgung. Wir sollten ein Recht darauf haben, online bezahlen und spenden zu können, ohne dass unsere Finanztransaktionen personalisiert aufgezeichnet werden. Also erstmal na ja ein Punkt.
Es gibt keine Rechtfertigung für diese faktische Abschaffung anonymer virtueller Zahlungen, wo bisher virtuelle Vermögenswerte für kriminelle Aktivitäten verwendet wurden, war eine Strafverfolgung auf der Grundlage der geltenden Vorschriften möglich,
Stimmt,
ein komplettes Verbot anonymer Grippezahlungen wird keine nennenswerten Auswirkungen auf die Kriminalität haben. Das erklärte Ziel der Geldwäsche und
das das erklärte Ziel Geldwäsche und Terrorismus zu bekämpfen ist nur ein Vorwand um immer mehr Kontrolle
über unsere privaten Geschäfte zu erlangen.
Ja also äh ich finde ja dieses dieses Cherry Picking da mit irgendwie ja da gibt es einzelne Personen, die würden ja sonst keine Spenden bekommen. Sorry, aber das ist wirklich nicht das große Problem hier. Also ja, mag ja sein.
Man kann aber auch andererseits auch sagen, dass jetzt die die Anonymität nicht das große Problem ist.
Es ist ja eh nicht anonym. Es ist bestenfalls Pseudonym
Also es ist alles nachvollziehbar. Es ist äh sehr sehr viel besser nachvollziehbar als äh sonstige Transaktion. Du kannst irgendwie in dieser Blockchain jede einzelne Transaktion nachverfolgen und es gibt immer bessere Analyse-Tools, die das auch sehr wohl tun.
So, also von daher ist diese ganze Anonymität ist ohnehin Quatsch, ja und äh,
ich da gehe ich wirklich mit Patrick nicht nicht nicht mit und dieses ganze ja es gibt da irgendwelche Youtuber in äh in Kambodscha, die ja sonst nicht überleben können. Das sind einfach solche Ablenkungs.
Die Sache ist.
Also es geht ja hier um die namentliche Registrierung aller, ne? Also wenn du sagst, die Bitcoin die die Blockchain ist nachvollziehbar, ja schön,
das steht nicht da ist nicht derjenige der dir das Wallet hat muss nicht deine Adresse haben. Ja und das das ist ja das es ging ja hier um die vollständige Aufhebung der der Pseudonymität zu dieses Wallet gehört Tim Pritt Love.
Gut, aber wenn du irgendwann wieder in in das normale äh Geld zurückgehst, dann musst du quasi eine Exchange benutzen und es geht ja gar nicht anders.
Ja du geht schon, ne? Kannst ja hier in irgend so eine Bitcoin Bar gehen und dir Bargeld auszahlen lassen.
Aber nicht in großen.
Kommt drauf an,
ähm du hast Recht und aber und genau da wollen Sie ja hin. Ne, dass das eben ähm und das kann potenziell, wenn du mal die ganze Skamerei weglässt, natürlich, wenn man das jetzt weltweit machen würde,
würde das potentiell den Set echt ein Problem machen, weil die also ich meine, die müssen ohnehin schon irgendwie sich sehr bemühen mit ihrer Geldwäsche.
Aber das könnte natürlich dann sehr sehr äh sehr sehr schwer werden. Einigen wir uns auf.
Ähm unentschieden und äh wir werden sehen, wie wie's wie äh das weitergeht.
Sie haben ja mal bei Bargeld haben Sie ja so eine Obergrenze gemacht. Das das also das könnte ich mir als eine oder diskutiert. Ich glaube, die haben's nicht gemacht. Da wollten Sie sagen, über 15.000 Euro darfst du nicht mehr in bar bezahlen.
Ich glaube, das ist damals nicht durchgekommen, wenn ich mich recht.
Nee, ich glaube auch nicht, aber.
Glaube, da ging's halt darum, dass irgendwelche schwerkriminellen nicht mehr die ganze Zeit Häuser in bar kaufen.
Aber das Geldwäscheproblem ist ein reales Problem, ja?
Geld wird in großen Mengen irgendwo kriminell erschlichen und es muss irgendwo gewaschen werden so und äh das sind da ist natürlich diese ganze
Krypto-Asset-Welt äh wunderbar, um da irgendwie neue Kanäle aufzumachen und meiner Meinung nach müssten die halt auch äh,
gestoppt werden.
Könnte ja eine, vielleicht könnte ja eine Möglichkeit sein, dass man halt einem Exchange sagt, okay pass auf, Transaktionen über einen bestimmten Wert.
Oder Auszahlungen über einen bestimmten Wert darfst du nicht mehr machen ohne die Person zu identifizieren. Ja, das könnte ja äh damit könnte ja, sage ich mal, für den für den allgemeinen,
für unsere kleineren Geldwäschen äh genug äh äh Freiheit noch da sein, ja? Während dann eben in in wenn es um bestimmte größere Beträge geht, dass dann eine Registrierungs- und Identifizierungspflicht,
käme.
Ja
Vielleicht diskutieren die in die Richtung. Wir gucken mal. Wir werden jetzt noch weiter diskutieren. Vor allem bis jetzt noch nicht noch nicht so wirklich,
Äh konkretisiert, sondern, das muss man ja sagen ähm,
Das ist jetzt eine Idee der Verhandlungsführer des EU-Parlaments des Ministerrats und der Kommission ähm bei der Reform der Verordnung über die Ermittlungen von Angaben bei Geldtransfer. Also die haben.
Weil sie sich überlegt, sie möchten das äh haben und sie möchten außerdem ein öffentliches Register für nicht-konforme und nicht beaufsichtigte Anbieter haben, mit denen in der EU kein Handel betrieben werden darf.
Bin mal gespannt wie das gehen soll, aber ja die beraten jetzt darüber noch. Mal gucken, wie sie das formulieren werden.
Das bringt uns dann äh zu den Terminen.
Am 278. findet der,
Tag des offenen Hackers statt. Bisher haben sich da fünfzig Hackers Spätschicht schon schon angeschlossen. In äh Deutschland, Schweiz, Österreich. Ähm gibt's eine schöne Karte,
Äh wo ich direkt meinen Fehler gefunden habe, der Chaos-Computer Club Berlin wird da in Basel äh.
Ist er ausgewandert, ja?
Pin ist in Basel. Der Pin ist in Berlin, aber der die Adresse ist dann in Basel. Da müsst ihr nochmal gucken. Ähm aber ja, ich find's eigentlich eine schöne Idee, weil Hackerspace ist jetzt nicht unbedingt äh,
immer dafür bekannt sind, die die offenste Tür der Stadt zu haben,
und äh das ist glaube ich auch schätze ich auch viel ein ähm,
vielleicht Vorurteil, dass oft bestätigt wird, aber da einfach mal Leute einzuladen, zu sagen, guck mal hier, 3D-Drucker, Elektroniklabore, hier Hacker, Maker, Bastard, kommt alle her. Das ist doch äh ganz schön.
Österreich ist nicht dabei Schweiz und Luxemburg. Was ist mit Österreich? Was ist mit dem Metalapp.
Was erlaube. Also ja, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht ähm hat da keiner angerufen, aber hier ist auch was mit Österreich. Doch,
Realraum AT ist hier mit verzeichnet. Also Österreichs. Auch dabei ist nur nicht besonders äh prominent äh vertreten,
hier in Linz. Irgendwie gibt's auch noch
Also, man sollte vielleicht nochmal kurz sagen, das ist dann halt auch das erste Mal, dass es so etwas gibt, dass es sozusagen eine neue Idee und ich finde die Idee super. Ich finde das sehr gut und äh ich bin gespannt, was dort
in den Hockerspaces dann so gezeigt und angeboten wird, auf jeden Fall.
Eine Editierung für diese Karte? Nee.
Ja?
Edit mache ich jetzt mache ich jetzt mache ich jetzt anders.
Okay, super. Dann passen wir das einfach an.
Mehr kann ich mit alles machen.
Ist nicht richtig, so wie Wikipedia, oder? Nee.
Weiß nicht genau. Ich kann hier.
Na gut.
Irgendwie warte mal, ich kann da pinnen. Klicke um einen Marker hinzuzufügen, der ich will ja einen existierenden editieren.
So geht das ja nicht irgendwie also weißt du?
Ah doch editieren. So Chaos, Computerclub Berlin. Marienstraße elf.
Editiert.
Ich editiere den gerade.
Ist ja ein Fuchs.
Marionstraße elf zehn elf neun glaube ich Berlin. Äh von wann bis wann weiß ich nicht.
Berlin CSU DE. Genau, aber es ist hier äh überall was zu finden. Äh sind diverse in Schleswig äh Holstein.
Den richtigen editiert.
Das hoffe ich ja auch. Nicht, dass die in Basel irgendwie sich jetzt wundern.
Stralsund, Bremen, was haben wir hier alles noch? Äh Minden sehe ich hier ähm Bielefeld sogar. Wer hätte es gedacht? Paderborn.
In ist was zu holen in Bochum selbstverständlich, das Labor, na klar, in Essen, der Chaos Pott Recklinghausen,
Überhaupt ist da im Pott eine Menge los. Das ist Wuppertal.
Werk in Wülfrath, das kannte ich noch gar nicht, Grasdorf in Düsseldorf, der Nordeingang. Toller Name. Neuss,
der C 4 in Köln selbstverständlich, Aachen auch dabei. Ja und vielleicht schließen sich ja bis dahin.
Gar nicht an einem Tag.
Auch noch einige an. Also wenn ihr jetzt äh ein Hackerspace äh seid oder kennt oder äh Mitglied seid oder was auch immer und ihr habt davon noch gar nichts mitbekommen und denkt sich nur so gute Güte, davon habe ich ja noch nichts mitbekommen
Na dann thematisiert das doch mal und vielleicht äh tretet ihr diesem Tag noch bei.
Genau. All right, wir wiederum.
Diesen Tag.
Jetzt aus.
Aus diesem Tag aus? Wir machen bei diesem Tag nicht mehr mit.
Genau.
Wurde hier nicht äh gebeten, mich diesem Tag anzuschließen. Er kam einfach.
Ja, der ist auch zerkratzt.
Der ist jetzt auch äh also der hat äh.
Es gebraucht.
Ausgedient.
Tag,
Leute. Wir verabschieden uns von euch und freuen uns, dass ihr uns hört und dass äh hoffen und hoffen, dass äh ihr uns auch Isma hört, wenn wir wieder sagen,
Guten Morgen Linus. Your breaking the protocall.
Nee, ich sage, es es heißt, er wird ciao ciao.
Meinetwegen auch das. Bis bald.
Ciao ciao.